hello guys Ryan right here
Katie du Bois Katie du Bois and I are
gonna check out marbles Jessica Jones
official trailer never dose I have seen
the first trailer have you no no and
honestly I forgot everything I knew
about the character all the research I
did before watching this video I
realized you know what this thing should
be good on its own terms without me
having to read the comic that's what
Veronica first said yeah eventually I
finally got to get in good for you is
that good good for you is that what you
need right now great great job thank you
that's cool make it a double or did the
office not a booth such a small room I
don't get asked on long second dates in
my line of work
you better know when to walk away but
some cases just won't let you go Jessica
Jones you tossed a man twice across the
ball with one hand his ability was to
eat people do whatever he might control
you want to do it
[Music]
you know to be someone yeah
what do I know her from oh that is mine
contrary investigator I'm resourceful
[Music]
and your weapons will die because it me
[Music]
like the hero's name
I could kill you right here right now
but you want because you don't know what
will happen when I die
[Music]
nice job
[Music]
[Music]
so super badass and fun I love it yeah I
saw the first trailer this one got me
really excited really excited yeah it
finally dawned on me like holy [ __ ] she
is perfect for this role so good she has
that level of like sarcasm and she's not
like typical Hollywood attractive kind
of her like rebellious sarcastic a
little playful like a little yeah and it
seems so unlikely yeah when you're
watching these action sequences you're
like I'm [ __ ] buying her doing really
so I love how she has such a personality
where you wouldn't expect it from really
that is so cool because anytime you see
a hero in a movie or show you see them
in the outfit it's never really that
much of a stretch of the imagination as
opposed to watching her where you're
like I can't see it and then when you
see the fight you're like oh [ __ ] it's
kind of like it reminds me of like when
we all saw Matt Damon do the Bourne
Identity
Matt Damon can't do that and then I see
him fight you're like holy [ __ ] Matt
Damon I thought you know that actress
like I when she first came out it was
like TV it was like don't trust the B in
apartment 23 and I saw trailers for that
and I was like uh I'm over it and then I
started watching her and she's so
talented and then of course Breaking Bad
you're talented I'm so amped for her in
this like it's a totally different look
a totally different character for her
and she's nailing it it's a totally
different character for us in general to
get like a Marvel female lead and it's
such a unique choice and I highly
[ __ ] love that I love that and I also
like so much what they're doing with the
villain I've totally forgot the villains
name sorry
he's got a very like you know queue in
Star Trek which was Q again Q is the guy
who is so like omnipotent that he is
able to like bounce around to do
whatever he wants and time and space and
know you guys will get it
someone's got me out there someone's got
my back on this Q from Star Trek
we can move on yeah he seems like a
great threat what well I love what we're
seeing from it's similar to how I felt
about daredevil was great hero and great
villain that is exactly what I'm feeling
here in a more supernatural sense was
like we got a great [ __ ] hero and a
great villain and I like the villains
it's like kingpins you know he's
physically destructive but he's really
about the mental game too and I and this
is like real mental game you know I mean
if the fight sequences are as good as
daredevil I'll be excited yeah I hope
the storytelling is as good as daredevil
yeah and a shot well like I want this to
be daredevil yeah hopefully there won't
be a weak link casting choice though
yeah like foggy I'm warming up to him
I'm warming up to it no I love you own
like foggy but Mike Colter is Luke Cage
though okay wait but can we like just
click on your monk like and kind of
think there's a little look at that oh
she's liking the black a dick look baby
I have no where's my baby I just think
like this is a damn handsome man oh my
god he is tall oh he's so tall don't you
think big dicks hurt I think that there
is a too big yeah he looks like you'd be
a too big you never know I must lead on
look at him you see a small penis
attached to that guy I I don't envision
that I would prefer not envision that a
bigger we talking that you Gandil I'm
not to having this conversation anymore
12 inches
fifteen yeah guys thanks for tuning into
the channel if you need to it subscribe
today by clicking this button above my
head become a reject Obot instead of
saying the same thing over and over
again I'm gonna call you guys something
different
reject a nugget maybe it needs to be
seasonal you know the holidays are
coming up is there some festive reject
reject turkey no Scheck timís reject
annika reject miss Catherine du Bois is
on Facebook Instagram Twitter and I
don't actually do anything whether the
YouTube channel but she has one of those
too so we still awkward it's you and I
so we still awkward we can make it more
awkward like yeah Brandon Davis you know
what's up right and friends just want to
see you the first and only reaction type
Channel I got it's cool I don't have a
problem I only check your videos out
like on the weekends what dude I don't
really post on the weekend sometimes
after work you know to unwind or
whatever why would you do you're off
work masturbate don't watch my videos
that's totally understandable we bring a
lot of attractive females on this
channel more importantly you got me but
it's totally cool cuz I can stop anytime
I want you know I can't I have it under
control I just completely lose I have
been fired for many a jobs I mean yeah
there was one time my friend came over I
came over oh you got it you got it and
found me passed out naked at my computer
we beat you to the joke open to your
YouTube page and all beat you to the
joke a little too predictable my friend
and I only have like six maybe seven
tabs open I mean everyone has one of
those nights am i right life of a rock
star Brandon Davis clearly got drunk and
wrote this message to the real rejects
yo it's a variety
open new tab you know you're one of the
better-looking subscribers listen this
is crabbers kind of look like me I don't
trust him I was trying to be nice now
you look like one of the serial killer
subscribers well-groomed though too well
groomed to be a serial killer no he's
one of the good-looking charming psycho
yeah it's like like oh look at this guy
he seems so warm and welcoming so
sensitive eyes but those eyes were the
devil's eyes oh wait no oh no my song I
thought I said Obama mm-hmm my house